tonight on the new reality the return of
kids sports it's going to look different
than it was about a few months ago the
future of day care we don't know how
much longer we could do this what are
our options here helping indigenous
youth they're dealing with isolation
they're stressed more stress than
they've ever been before we'll travel
take off we are now at a period of time
that we need to learn how to coexist
with the virus and preventing a second
wave if there's one thing we've learned
about this virus is that we can't
underestimate it
hello I'm Donna Friesen we're at that
time of the year that's usually so
exciting for kids school is out for the
summer
there are grad parties going on kids are
moving on to the next stage in their
lives this year all those milestones are
being marked virtually tonight we're
going to dig into the impact that's
having physically and psychologically
most kids haven't seen the inside of a
classroom in months have hardly seen
their friends and haven't played
organized sports screen time is up
activity is down a new study from
ParticipACTION gave Canadian kids a D+
on activity it found only 39 percent of
kids aged 5 to 17 met federal guidelines
for physical activity the one bright
spot 77 percent of 5 to 19 year olds
participated in some kind of organized
sport or physical activity both kids and
parents want to get back into the game
John hua takes us through the first
tentative steps down that path these
sounds are music to every hockey lovers
ear
but at the local rink it's a whole new
reality it's different I'll have to come
fully dressed and that actually has
taken away from their locker room time
with the team but it hasn't seemed to
phase the kids at all I think they're
just happy to be back and I'm from
designated entrances and walkways to
only a few parents in the stands the
Fraser Valley Kings hockey program in
Abbotsford British Columbia has drawn up
a whole new play from the covet 19
pandemic obviously keeping the kids six
feet apart there's an element of the
game that you can't teach or work on
right now but there's a lot of the
skills and the basics you know as the
kids get through it's about the
fundamentals the spring tournaments have
been cut the focus now is on player
development we haven't played a month so
I kind of forgot some things there's a
heavy emphasis on the importance of
social distancing on the ice and with
the limit of one parent per player at
the rink this camera and a couple of
clicks online well hockey moms or dads
to watch their child's progress from
home the family is they were loyal to me
and I promise to work really hard for
them to get them back in the rink and
giving them a program that was different
than originally thought but you know as
a group they wanted to be here
getting back to activities like hockey
could have easily been benched until a
later date but all levels of government
across Canada a prioritized a return to
play because of the added benefit sport
brings during this pandemic it really
demonstrates the power of sport in terms
of providing physical and mental health
benefits but also that connection in the
community how it brings people together
the Fraser Valley Kings are following
the guidelines provided by via sport
Legacy Program of the 2010 Vancouver
Olympic Games and now the BC
government's liaison for organized
sports the guidelines do kind of get and
hand it down to the local club and it's
really after them to say okay how do we
implement this
with what we've got and we need to wait
can we do this now what do we need to
adjust no matter what the sport the key
message is while it might be good to be
back and it's going to look different
than it was a few months ago and it also
may look different from community to
community based on those guidelines BC
hockey's current phase includes social
distancing no non-essential travel and
modified play no league competitions you
know no training camps right now and all
of these things for now yeah it's still
fun I wish I was playing games down for
associations like Ridge Meadows minor
hockey the future of this coming fall is
far from certain the speculation is the
challenge right now and we've worked
really hard we we have a number of
different scenarios and and plans in
place the season will almost certainly
start with skills development many are
still holding onto hope for the good old
hockey game we'd love to return to some
form of game play if we could it might
start out a small area gameplay you know
and then maybe roll into a three on
three or four and four format if we have
to ideally though we want to play five
on five hockey and that's the goal now
spectators are a major concern for every
sport organization because there are
plenty of parents siblings even
grandparents who want to watch their
loved ones play in British Columbia
there's currently a ban on any large
gathering of fifty people or more and
that number can get even smaller
depending on the size of the facility to
avoid having too many people in one
place at one time so according to via
sport the key rule still applies
really sorry the key rule still applies
you have to stay at least 2 meters away
from anyone around you and a reminder
that's a minimum in Oakville Ontario
these young soccer stars are finally
about to score some time with their team
not exactly train with them but still
see them and to act at them and that's I
feel is gonna be a lot better for all of
us a return to the pitch with a parent
or friend is one thing practicing with
their club helps these competitors push
one another to be better the intensity
isn't the exact same as you would but
being there with your teammates well
soccer Ontario unveiled its restart plan
in mid-june many clubs are just trying
to get off on the right foot
a recent survey showed 33 percent of
parents would return their kids to the
game 28 under strict conditions and more
than 12 percent would give a red card to
the rest of the year
you've seen that more in your
recreational type player whereas in your
more competitive player there's less
caution because they're willing to trust
the system and come back the drop in
registration and program fees has led to
an 80 percent drop in revenue and
reduction in staff the uncertainty has
Ontario soccer and many local clubs
worried from an economic recovery
standpoint we're looking at a minimum of
two years if not five years for parents
it's about juggling the need to be
cautious with Kovan 19 and knowing the
benefit the game brings when their kids
are together I'm more concerned about
his well-being mentally socially and so
you weigh that and I think we're in a
good place moving forward for these
phenom any kind of soccer will do the
trick
kicking it with their club will be that
much better baseball is considered to be
one of the safer sports to play during
this pandemic because it's outdoors and
mostly non-contact
but the London Badgers have just come
back to practice and not on the field
all at once the middle infielders are
going right now on the field the corner
infielders are hitting off in a
different area the outfielders are
coming to stretch right now
baseball Ontario is limiting return to
play
two regions in Phase two of the
provinces restart plan with a limit of
ten players for in-person play the
Badgers are going for even smaller
training groups of five these are just
my like my best buddies and my favorite
like people in the world so I just get
to see them and hang out and play what I
love with them and what happens when
avoiding the spread of covin nineteen
horses out the key safety component of
spotting from competitive gymnastics
that was definitely for me the hardest
thing physical distancing means no one
to guide them through these gravity
defying acts my coach that I trusts and
that has spotted me for years I wasn't
gonna have her spotting me and even like
after a skill like when you do it and
you feel happy like I want to just like
give her a hug but like I can flip City
gymnastics in Langley BC part of
bouncing back from this pandemic means
getting back up and pushing forward
within your limits we wanted to make
sure that coaches work with their
athletes to ensure that they're staying
within the scope of their current
abilities and not learning new things
too quickly as they return gymnastics BC
has already struck a delicate balance
no more spotting but also other new
measures including two metre markers
daily screenings and enhanced cleaning
sanitizing high touch areas takes on a
whole new spin when it's basically
everything in sight I think that first
day I think we were all very nervous and
anxious on what the process would look
like but as soon as those kids started
coming through the doors it was it was
just exhilarating seeing any of these
athletes in action there's no doubt this
is a rough time
for those on the cusp of reaching the
next level
they love to compete and we can't take
that away from them then that's what
they love to do so just be patient and
it will all come back but whether it's
on the high beam ball diamond soccer
pitch or ice
returned to play within this new reality
is a common goal across Canada this
pandemic may have forced each activity
in every community to adapt and change
the way we compete trying hard and doing
the drills right and doing them fast but
the drive to come together through sport
is something not even covet 19 can stop
that's the physical side lots of new
rules and adjustments and as we enter a
summer of uncertainty and change it's
having an impact on mental health to the
school closures learning online limited
contact with friends and the
cancellation of activities is unsettling
it's hard to measure the scale of the
problem because it's still unfolding
experts do say they've seen a
significant increase in demand for
counseling services Canada's largest
Pediatrics center the Hospital for Sick
Children in Toronto is leading a study
examining the mental health impact of
the co bid 19 measures on children youth
and families
Jennifer Crosby is a clinical
psychologist and health clinician
scientist within the department of
psychiatry at sick kids hospital
professor Crosby thanks for taking time
to speak with us tell me about this
study you're involved in who's taking
part what are you measuring and tracking
absolutely so when the Kovach measures
were put into place very quickly those
of us who are working in mental health
research came together to try to see how
we could understand what the impact is
on children families and youth so four
major mental health studies that were
already happening in Ontario quickly
came together so that we could create a
survey and a mechanism of reaching out
to families virtually and finding out
how they were doing how they were coping
with these emergency measures that were
in place and we're gonna track these
families over the next 12 months because
it's not just about the initial measures
and what the impact was but what's the
impact over time I know there are huge
variations in how kids cope but in broad
terms can you tell us what the studies
revealed so far about the impact of
pandemic has had it's very much in line
with international data that is showing
that children and parents are reporting
a
increase across a range of concerns such
as anxiety and mood irritability and
attention and concentration really a
very large percentage of respondents
have said that parents have noticed an
increase in these traits from before
kovat and also a lot of uncertainty and
worry about what's going to happen down
the line you know kids especially
younger ones tend to want to know what
the plan is what is happening next with
all this uncertainty now not even
knowing if they'll be back in class in
the fall what does that uncertainty
potentially lead to it has been very
difficult and that uncertainty is a key
part of that you know I think everybody
initially when the emergency measures
went into place there was a families had
to cope and come up with new strategies
of dealing with that and and to some
degree I think that became a new normal
for families but now as we head into
summer and school ends again we have a
whole new section for kids to to kind of
think about so by and large camps are
not happening if they are happening
they're happening in a very different
way sport programs not happening there's
still a lot of uncertainty and you know
every day and every week there's an
update and a change and that uncertainty
uncertainty can be very difficult for
kids who's most at risk of developing
mental health challenges because of this
pandemic you know we don't know the
answer to that and that was really one
of the most important elements of this
study is that this is unprecedented
there's so many factors that we need to
consider that this data is gonna really
be key in helping us understand what the
impact is and what would be important
moving forward if perhaps we need to
think about or plan more emergency
measures if there's a second wave or
that this goes on for a longer period of
time we're really hoping that this data
is going to help us plan and perhaps
identify the kids who we should be and
the families and the youth that we
should be touching base with earlier and
perhaps providing targeted interventions
to help them cope and manage better in
these uncertain times
you know kids look to us as role models
how important is it that we manage our
own anxiety and take care of ourselves
and not put too much pressure on
ourselves to plan the perfect summer
absolutely I think that's a really
important message
kids do look to adults as their
emotional barometer as such and so
modeling managing our anxieties and our
worries and sort of being in the moment
setting up some routines that work for
your family based on the new situation
pride providing some normalcy within you
know your family life we can't control
what's going to happen in a month or two
months or with school or with covin well
you know we can set aside dinner times
times of days or times in the week when
we play games together things we do as a
family you can really set a new routine
and a new pace within with a family and
then then kids can really rely on those
expectations and they can oh well these
things these things are gonna stay
stable and so while there's other things
that are maybe a little bit uncertain
these are the things that I can count on
so wherever you live across the country
figuring out what is allowable and then
kind of facilitating and helping kids
get out and reconnect with their social
networks to sort of help them re-engage
that part of their life which is so
important to them if you have young
children you know the challenge of
looking after them and trying to work
it's a constant exhausting juggle for a
lot of parents child care is essential
and it's just not back to where it was
pre-pandemic
a national survey conducted for the
Canadian child care Federation found
that 36 percent of childcare centers
that closed because of kovat 19 might
not reopen at all and 38 percent of home
daycares could remain closed those that
are reopening face a precarious
financial future sixty-eight percent say
they're worse off than they were before
Mike Joel a looks at the rocky road to
recovery of child care
every day in cities and towns across the
country kids are dropped off to start
their days
it's about socialization the economy and
the collective sanity of parents
everywhere oh she loves de coeur I
absolutely loves it
Beatrice had only been in daycare three
months when everything shut down for her
mama
Julia Mackenzie it meant balancing the
work she had just returned to with the
needs of a toddler she now had to care
for 24 hours a day so maybe about three
weeks ago we both kind of said okay we
don't know how much longer we can do
this we need some help
do we need to hire a nanny what's what
are our options here there's a lot of
guilt and familiarity to parents in
those words with no familial support
because of kovat 19 Beatrice spent more
time in front of the TV than normal and
no time interacting with other kids
after three months she's become
distrustful of others and in the street
when people walk too close to her I
noticed she clings to me so that's been
a huge concern actually it scares me a
little bit I don't want her to become
fearful and I don't want her to learn
that it's not okay to to play with
people but in the new reality Beatrice
who returns to daycare on Monday is one
of the lucky ones because there are
fewer childcare spots available BC has
implemented strict rules when it comes
to contact and distancing with children
but has an assigned a number for how
large groups can be Manitoba recently
removed its size restrictions Quebec
will follow suit in July but Alberta
Saskatchewan Ontario New Brunswick and
Nova Scotia have imposed strict limits
to keep groups small which has
effectively shrunk the system's capacity
a Toronto city councilor estimates there
will be 56,000 fewer spots in Toronto
alone Amy O'Neill of treetop childcare
says her Center can't opened under the
current limit of 10 people per room
including teachers so we usually have
approximately 155 but we're licensed for
many more
with the new reopening guidelines I can
accommodate 24 financially she says
they'd be bankrupt within two months and
on a personal note she wants nothing to
do with the lotteries other centers have
used to assign the spots they do have
that's not our business to decide who is
eligible and who is not O'Neill is
waiting for direction from the
government until then she and the
families that rely on her are in limbo
in Peterborough the staff of nearly a
dozen daycares decided the situation was
untenable and recently took to the
streets to protest Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau did announce an aid package this
past week stating what some critics say
was pretty obvious
well childcare is gonna require more
spaces more rooms more space different
modifications which will cost more money
so we want to be there to help that
child care advocates are asking that 2.5
billion of the 14 billion dollars
pledged be earmarked to help address
critical issues beyond that Carolyn
ferns of the Ontario Coalition for
better childcare says the guidelines as
a whole are far too restrictive and
Ontario children can be picked up either
teachers provided a blanket is between
them and that blanket can't be used
again I know that from early childhood
educators that I have spoken with that's
one of their top concerns they don't
want to be running a childcare program
with children in chalk squares and even
more perplexing is this nugget from the
provinces 20 pages of guidelines
children should not do activities that
involve sharing toys and they should
avoid singing that's just not a
realistic expectation considering the
push for small groups home daycares
would seem to be a logical alternative
over a half of we watch as thousand
homes continue to operate during the
pandemic and they have a list of new
daycares ready to go but the first aid
courses they need for certification are
still closed
we could have 120 spaces available
pretty quickly but we can't get the
certification and we've asked if they
could do small group sizes like
one-on-ones or maybe three providers
the room capable social distance them we
can do the whole thing how do we work
around this and we just can't seem to
get anywhere it's more red tape more
rules more uncertainty for an essential
service I don't know they keep saying
it's based on medicine and evidence and
I wonder if it's more political putting
excessive guidelines around children is
impractical argues dr. Anna Banerjee
because they're considered low-risk to a
virus that is unlikely to be completely
eradicated I don't think we can contain
it I think slowed it down but I think
until we have a vaccine or until there's
no immunity Co it's gonna be around for
watch these next few months will be
critical for child care providers to
prove they can handle outbreaks and
provide a reprieve for parents it's
having a huge impact on people as well
you can only hold back the floodgates
for so long
still ahead I swear I taking the oath
that I will be faithful the new reality
of becoming a Canadian citizen and up
next we have to keep our guard up advice
from BCS top doctor until we have either
an effective treatment or a vaccine I
don't see large gatherings in our near
future dr. Bonnie Henry on the future of
weddings opening the border and
preventing a second wave
[Music]
when the news broke back in March that
BC had Canada's first death from Kovac
19 in a long-term care home in North
Vancouver just across the water from
here there was fear would BC become the
epicenter of an outbreak in Canada it
could have if it weren't for the quick
and smart response from DC's provincial
health officer the New York Times called
her the top doctor who aced the
coronavirus test dr. Bonnie Henry has
barely had a day off since the beginning
of 2020 and it's her decisive action and
clear calm communication that's kept B
C's numbers low be kind to be calm and
to be safe to be kind to be calm and to
be safe words many NBC live by and words
that have become so popular there's a
cottage industry of Bonnie Henry
merchandise for sale most of the
proceeds going to charity from the start
of the pandemic people connected to her
intelligence and her empathy and
following her advice has saved lives BC
has lost just over a hundred and seventy
people to kovat nineteen Ontario which
has three times the number of people has
had more than 15 times as many deaths
and this is not over the virus has not
vanished and this summer is going to be
another test dr. Bonnie Henry is with me
from Victoria dr. Henry when I first
interviewed you in early April there was
no talk about lifting restrictions case
numbers were still rising now it's
almost July and restrictions are being
lifted in phases almost everywhere and
you say that this will be a unique
summer are you nervous if there's one
thing we've learned about this virus is
that we can't underestimate it and we
have to keep our guard up I think we've
done that really well here in DC so I'm
not sure I'm nervous I do have an
underlying level of anxiety that started
in January hum that continues but if
people continue to do what we've been
able to do here in BC and
you know I'm focusing on making sure our
public health teams are ready to do our
part as well and we've been able to do
that you know we will see cases but I
believe we can manage that you're
advising people to keep their bubbles
small this summer as Canadians plan
their vacations what do you think they
should aim for not just in BC but
elsewhere in Canada too you know I think
it's really important for us to to take
the summer to have some time to breathe
and to connect with the people that are
important to us in our lives
but we also have a can't lose sight of
the fact that this pandemic is still
ongoing so we need to find that that
balance so keeping small numbers of
people where we would have the big
family gathering of 100 150 it needs to
be much smaller than that this year do
you think it's likely that gatherings
like big weddings and funerals and
conventions might be too risky to hold
until there's a vaccine yes I think that
unfortunately is the way it's going to
be for the near future this is not
forever but definitely for the coming
months into the fall until we have
either an effective treatment or vaccine
large gatherings like that just are too
risky you know you've got some power dr.
Henry your calm guidance has made BC a
model for the rest of the world in new
york times as you know calls you the
doctor who aced the coronavirus test and
now you've even told the NHL it has to
abide by your rule so you're not going
compromise those rules so Vancouver can
be a hub for NHL games what's your
bottom line on the NHL I don't know that
that's the particular reason we did have
discussions through the Canucks around
some of the things that I think are
important and you know for me and us
here in public health in the Health
System here focusing on maintaining the
health making sure that we don't
compromise any of the work that we've
put in and be
the two protecting our communities here
and it's also important to make sure
that any of the teams the players that
came to BC were also protected so there
is no compromise on that at all let me
ask you about the American border I know
it's not your job to decide whether it
reopens or not but given what you see is
happening in many states the surge in
cases would you want it to open in July
you know we we have had many talks with
our federal counterparts about this I do
think it's important to have family
reunification and we've been supporting
that but no opening for visitors right
now is very risky for us and I think my
colleagues across Canada we all feel
quite strongly about that the
million-dollar question right now is
will there be a second wave what are
your fears about that and what do you
think are our biggest vulnerabilities to
that in Canada right now what I would
like to see in our best-case scenario is
that we continue to grumble along and
control things maybe at some point we
can get it down to no cases in a couple
of days but um you know realistically
looking at what's happened around the
world it's likely that we will see
surges will see small outbreaks as we
have more people who are getting
together and that's why it's so
important for us to keep our numbers of
connections low so that we can find
people quickly that we can do the work
in public health to contain it but we
need to be prepared that when
respiratory season starts we may see an
uptick in both influenza and kovat and
we'll need to be able to manage that to
have the testing capacity and the
contact tracing capacity so that's what
we're planning for for the fall and
we'll hope for the best but as somebody
has said to me hope is not a strategy so
we need to plan for what will happen
should we start getting more cases
particularly when influenza season
starts where did your mantra be kind be
calm be safe come from it really was a
bit of a compilation you know I was
trying to
figure out how we could get the message
across that we need to be in this
together and we need to understand where
other people are coming from we are in
this storm the same storm but we're not
all in the same boat and by supporting
each other and doing what we need to do
together is how we'll all get through
this storm coming up am I making the
right choice
putting travel to the test we are now
that we need to learn how to coexist
with the virus how Airlines and
passengers are preparing to fly again
[Music]
as businesses big and small across
Canada begin to reopen there's one
sector that has stalled travel
especially the airline industry
Air Canada has laid off 20,000 people
more than half of its workforce and this
week WestJet announced it is laying off
more than 3,300 workers domestic flights
are still happening though much reduced
its international air travel that's
really tanked passenger arrivals at
Canadian airports were down 95 percent
last week compared to 2019 that's
according to the Canada Border Services
Agency if you do decide to fly the rules
around air travel are changing both for
airlines and for passengers Christel the
man singh shows us how the Colosseum is
an iconic symbol of the past its future
however rests in the sanitized hands of
its visitors so many of the world's top
attractions are reopening but to fall in
love with these sights something else
has to happen first
[Music]
people have to start flying again hi my
name is Miranda de Pernod and I was last
on a flight April 28th flying from
Montreal to Vancouver April was the
worst month on record for the aviation
sector the industry bottomed out as the
deadly pandemic swept across Europe and
over to North America the company that
directs air traffic above the UK some of
the busiest airspace in the world
created this flight comparison showing
just how different the sky appeared in
April 2019 compared to April this year I
[Music]
felt pretty alright with things I think
perhaps has to do with my age but I know
my mom was very nervous about flying and
everyone yeah everyone on the fly it was
like fully some people were in full like
painter's suits with their hair tucked
away and goggles and masks and gloves
and everything most I mean everyone had
a mask on
most people had gloves on and then the
the energy of the flight I could feel
the air so just intense like you could
hear a pin drop
what a surreal experience yeah even just
I mean the body language of the people
around you you know I think we've kind
of gotten into this place with flight to
China claim space and I can feel instead
of you know people's shoulders being
back and kind of spreading out wine to
take that space it was almost the exact
opposite where it was all these layers
and scarves and just people wanted as
much you know to be kept to themselves
as possible keeping ourselves locked
away at home was exactly what we were
all directed to do now the message is
changing we are now at a period of time
that we need to learn how to coexist
with the virus the International Air
Transport Association says resuming air
travel is key to restarting economies
however the agency's own polling shows
fliers in 11 countries including Canada
or hesitant three sets of polls by
IATA shows overall concern about the
virus remains high for Canadians going
from 63% in February to 80% this month
when it comes to the question of
returning to travel the majority of
those polled 55% say they'll wait at
least six months before traveling hello
my name is Ronnie Solomon and I flew
from London UK to Toronto Canada on June
19th I had a lot of anxiety around that
because I was like am I making the right
choice
traveling it wasn't busy it wasn't
followed by any means and I think that
went a long way in alleviating some of
the stress that I had because the middle
seats were all blocked out and while I
was placed in a pod of three the middle
seat was empty and then there was a
gentleman sitting on the aisle side
public health is a new layer to air
travel safety the industry is
replicating what's being done in other
sectors to try and protect people from
kovat 19 masks are universal temperature
checks are widely used some countries
are opting to test travellers and
cleaning efforts have been enhanced in
airports and on planes non-essential
foreign travel is still not recommended
for Canadians but come next month the
plan is for most of Europe to reopen to
international visitors a big part of the
reason comes down to money
Greece is ready to welcome tourists this
summer by putting their safety and their
health as our number one priority in
some countries visitors have to
quarantine but there is a huge amount of
pressure from industry on governments to
scrap those restrictions they're seen as
yet another barrier to restarting air
travel from this vantage point at London
City Airport we should be watching lots
of planes coming and going but there
just isn't the demand Airlines this year
expect to post a loss of 84 million
dollars and that will have a ripple
effect on millions of jobs
attached to the sector the passenger is
going to have more responsibilities he's
going to have to be fit for travel which
in the different in the path wasn't
necessarily the case
but that's what's going to help us
reduce the risk but many people don't
know they're sick travel has led to new
infections New Zealand was virus-free
four weeks until two seemingly healthy
women visited from the UK and ended up
testing positive Beijing saw flights
canceled recently and new clusters of
cope at nineteen led to localised
lockdowns
this is where risk because it's such an
interesting concept to mull over my
personal opinion is if you don't need to
travel then don't travel until there's
some kind of you know vaccine or people
are feeling comfortable with where the
numbers are at I do think the way that
we gather around one another be it in a
plane or on the bus or on the subway
there's definitely gonna be a new
awareness and consciousness that's who
is around you and what sounds sneezes
fluids are may be coming area the
industry is working to rebuild consumer
confidence the recovery from kovat
nineteen is expected to take years
airlines are banking on there not being
a second wave and on our desire to get
back out and see the world
next on the new reality give yourself
one more day creating a lifeline is a
tough time but good things are coming
from it
the new program helping Canada's
indigenous youth when they need it most
[Music]
the impact of the pandemic on a mental
health of Canadians is still being
measured but we know social isolation
uncertainty about the future is having
an impact and it's especially acute in
indigenous communities a new survey this
week from stats Canada found 60% of
indigenous people say their mental
health has worsened since the onset of
physical distancing measures overall 38
percent reported fair or poor mental
health that's 22 percent higher than in
the most recent Aboriginal peoples
survey well before Kovan 19 too many
young indigenous people were crying out
for help as Jeff's simple tells us
there's at least one new resource now
offering help that's a phone call away
Ashley Cummings childhood photos carry
mixed emotions he everybody the good
times growing up in Nunavut snowmobiling
with her parents and the tough times as
a teenager losing several cousins and
friends to suicide suicide has been a
very prominent part of my life for well
since I was a young child as an emic she
knows all too well how the suicide rate
among Inuit is one of the highest in the
world almost ten times the Canadian
average and when she was 16 she almost
became one of those statistics cuz it
was just such a very visceral pain that
I was being where I guess I was almost
subjecting myself through because I
didn't know how to deal with any of it
but she found a lifeline in the form of
a text message conversation with an
anonymous volunteer from Kids Help Phone
they were able to figure it out and help
me take the advice and listen and and
get me out of that crisis mode thank you
for calling Kids Help Phone how can I
help you
the Canadian charity has provided
counseling services for over three
decades and launched a new program last
year targeting indigenous youth looking
of course a service use and doing
everything we can to ensure we're
reaching indigenous young people where
they live and and that our services are
meeting their unique needs the manager
of the program called finding hope says
they're expanding and promoting their
services in indigenous communities such
as pine house Saskatchewan the remote
northern village is home to breathtaking
beauty and terrible poverty Kids Help
Phone is partnering with a local
photography club helping youth to see
the world through a different lens
Photography saved my life and and the
beauty seeing the beauty through a lens
and instead of looking at the past you
know that and going through the rough
times think
for many First Nations maintain Inuit
kids across Canada they don't have
access to health or mental health
services or supports on a regular basis
Kids Help Phone offers support remotely
24/7 by phone online chat and text
message if young people's eyes are on a
screen right now and that's where the
mental health supports need to be at the
start of the year they were receiving
more than a thousand text messages per
month from indigenous youth and that was
before the biggest mental health crisis
the organization has ever seen go home
and stay home this is what we all need
to be doing
and I just know how stressful it is for
a healthcare system for my colleagues
and for families the kovat 19 pandemic
and baktun saw demand for kids help
phone services skyrocket more than 1,500
cries for help
calls and messages every day up three
hundred and fifty percent compared to
last year they're dealing with isolation
they're stressed more stress than
they've ever been before there's a lot
of grieving and loss young people who
aren't able to connect with their
friends maybe they're missing graduation
and then we've also seen a real increase
in contacts around other things like
abuse and neglect so for some young
people home is not a safe place the
charity has called emergency services
around ten times a day during the
pandemic when needed to respond to a
suicide attempt and that need is
greatest in communities that were
already struggling the anxiety that
indigenous youth feel is heightened in a
lot of respects for for a number of
reasons I mean there isn't the same
access to health care in a lot of these
remote communities we're telling people
over and over again wash your hands wash
your hands but now we have a hundred or
so First Nations that are on water
advisories right now where that might
not be safe we've got poverty which is
affecting so many indigenous young
people and we don't have space to
socially isolate or physically isolate
within the home these things are causing
anxiety for young people faced with that
unprecedented need kids help phone
called for backup
asking ordinary Canadians to volunteer
to provide emotional support to
anonymous strangers over text message
the charity's chief youth officer admits
it was a big ask we put a call out we
said hey people across Canada raise your
hand
join us take a training it's a 36 hour
training they do a police background
check and then they sign on to our
platform and the response was over well
we had almost nine thousand Canadians
raised their hand and say that they
wanted to be a part of supporting young
people which to me was huge we are on
track right now to train more people in
the next few weeks than we have trained
in the last two years together one of
those volunteer crisis responders says
it's a win-win there's very few
volunteer opportunities I believe that
you can walk at the end of your shift or
walk at the end your day and say wow
I've potentially saved someone's life
today and thanks to those volunteers for
the first time in its history Kids Help
Phone is now also offering services to
adults more and more adults were coming
to us and they were starting the
conversation with I'm so sorry I'm not a
kid or can I use the service and we
realize there aren't enough places for
adults who are also going through the
same distress the same isolation it's a
tough time but good things are coming
from it Dunham's says they've also
received a large number of indigenous
volunteers offering to provide support
to others in need one of them is Ashley
Cummings now a member of the charity's
indigenous advisory council I feel like
I'm doing so much better now
it definitely makes me emotional knowing
that a lot of other youth are facing
very similar or the same kind of
circumstances where they're it just
feels like there's too much I think my
message would be to just give yourself
one more day it's all about those little
baby steps that build up to large feats
of figuring out your mental health
[Music]
anyone who needs mental health support
can call kids help phone at one eight
hundred six six eight six eight six
eight or text six eight six eight six
eight the service is available 24 hours
a day and as we mentioned it's for kids
and adults the new reality we'll be
right back
among the countless things put on hold
by the pandemic where citizenship
ceremonies that moment when newcomers
take the oath that makes them officially
Canadian like so much these days those
moments have migrated to online and last
week in a digitally adapted ceremony the
latest crop of new Canadians raised
their hands I swear that I will be
faithful a simple oath that's a
life-changing moment these new Canadians
all of whom were forced to flee their
homeland of Syria searching for a new
beginning finding one in Canada now
starting life in a new safe place to
call home as a Canadian citizen released
a CEO to honor them and all new
Canadians we leave you with the a
cappella voices of the west coast
harmony chorus from Surrey BC I'm Donna
Friesen goodnight
[Music]
Oh
[Music]